yeah
Gant's is an anime by gonzo animation
studio so after hearing this I could
already assume a few things about the
anime animation quality and randomly
fluctuate the anime would probably
differentiate from the manga nearly
endless series causing it to have a
completely different ending and there
would be crappy CG included that will
stick out as much as a girl attending a
Star Trek convention so after watching
the series I can say that I was pretty
much bottled in all three assumptions
the story of Gantz goes like this okay
Corona is your typical horny selfish
high school student who one day by
chance is forced to help his childhood
friend Kaito rescue a drunken hobo who's
falling on the train tracks are
teresting the hobo the both particularly
died from an incoming train due to their
complete inability to climb over a
two-foot wall moments later they are
transported into a room filled with
other people who have also supposedly
died gathered around a black ball named
Gant's from this point on their force by
dance to participate in games of alien
hunting's of great dangers and horrors
all while wearing the gantt suit an
outfit resembling a skin-tight
Evangelion Ginsu that's been tentacle
raped which when he didn't really shout
slicked squad of assassins murdering
countless aliens but was more the office
way of telling the cosplayers why not
have a go if you think you're hard
enough as far as the class goes the main
character kei is depicted as lack of a
better word a [ __ ] but wait that's not
all because apparently all humans in a
series of potatoes can't except for a
course Saito who's just a big soft [ __ ]
and evidently the only big soft [ __ ]
any emcee of dicks that present in this
series hmm an allergy made more sense in
my head oh and there's also cake issue
Mona but she might as well be replaced
by a pair of tits attached to a long
stick and it would serve the same
purpose as she does now anyway this was
a very violent and me complete with
plenty of gore and a ridiculously high
body count one thing I actually liked
about Gans was that no character was
safe and everyone seems to be so
disposable
I mean sure at the beginning of a
mission dude have your usual set of
characters whose death is so predictable
they might as well be the only black guy
and horribly be walking down a dark
basement by himself and uttering the
phrase I'll be right back
but some characters died Hugh think
we'll survive he just can't tell who
live and who will die the end of a
mission which I thought was cool it's
actually built up some proper tension in
the series there's also plenty of new T
in the show with nipples being shown at
the drop of a hat which is partly due to
the fact that Gore needs he fill out to
piss as a kebab shop but probably mainly
due to the main character since it's
likely the horniest [ __ ] in the
history of horny [ __ ] the
average person thinks about sex every 7
seconds but 4k seems more like every no
point five seconds and for every other
more point five seconds he's thinking
about how to get sex I mean it seems
like he's forgotten
the whining 90 piece of skin surrounding
tits and vagina called the woman isn't
that right K not now I'm not gonna stiff
oh oh oh and just quick warning there is
a sex scene in this Annie for some
reason as if there's an we needed the
bigger hardened for herself one problem
I had with the series was that pace was
just so bloody slow and just takes ages
for characters to actually decide to do
something for example in one of the
beginning episode Kaito just stands
there debating the ethics of killing an
alien off it is just Coralie murdered
about five other people in front of him
while the alien just politely stands
there picking his nose with the gun
pointed at him perhaps due to his
well-bred manners or letting someone
decide whether or not he should kill you
when you could just easily tear him limb
from limb his stand-up goes on for about
ten slow agonizing minutes and I don't
know what would be more the fact that
Kaito should just pulled the trigger the
fact that the alien just stands end
there's nothing autopilot everyone run
just watches and does [ __ ] we'll about
it damage in his series doesn't really
make sense either since in the first few
episodes one of the main characters
almost dies from blood loss when he gets
his wrist slightly cut but later on in a
series get to your arms and legs sliced
off seems to be as life-threatening as a
[ __ ] splinter and about as painless
as one as well apparently the animation
in this series I thought was great well
all except for the CD bits at least
which was basic Ando animation studio
wavering around the big 3d effects penis
in an attempt to make the animation
cooler and more fan whack bore something
bollocks merely he just looks like a
five-year-old made the 3d models using
play-doh and animates as smoothly as a
pig riding a unicycle as far as the
ending goes
I thought you anime ended just that
started to get good and I was left
wanting more which really annoyed me to
me the main bulk of the anime was the
dative due to the flat like I could see
that potentially this anime could get to
be really good and just as we started to
see the character development of K the
cont Takei the super badass [ __ ]
whose silicon but now has some bloody
balls the anime just ends abruptly hey
that guy's one bad mother--
Elmo
yeah yeah you dig it can check over
Athol gaps was a good anime even there
was a bit slow it was a very addictive
and me but because of the pace I found I
had to watch many episodes in a row
until felt satisfied though the ending
was rushed and overall just [ __ ] the
manga does continue on the storyline for
all you manga fans out there
all in all you should think of Gantz as
a teenage boy who's just reach beauty
and it's discovering his new taste he
has a slight obsession with gore and has
trouble not getting a hard-on anytime
members of the opposite sex are near him
overall I give this anime a 7 out of 10
Google called about powerlessness it